(upbeat music)
- Polygon Studio is a design tool
that allows users to create
these polarized light mosaics
using custom mosaic designs.
Users can create their mosaic design
using a vector drawing
tool of their choice.
Once they have that they
can import their design
into Polygon Studio and Polygon Studio
recolors the design to use
the closest matching colors
in the database, which was computed
from the user supply of cellophane
and once they have one design in,
they can import another mosaic design.
And when they import
multiple mosaic designs
it allows them to create these
color changing behaviors,
which they can also
preview using the tool.
So there is an interactive mode
that lets users preview the
color changing behaviors
and understand exactly
how these mosaics work
by rotating the constituent
components of the mosaic.
So once they're happy with
all the colors in their design
and all the color changing effects,
they can export their
design for fabrication
and cut it up with a laser cutter.
(upbeat music)
I think a lot of people think about
how technological progress can inspire art
but not how art can inspire
technological process.
So just thinking about
it in an inverse way
I think is really cool.